what's the other batman theme
[Music]
i got frustrated man well i'm sorry it's
a little frustrating for me you like
batman right it's my favorite superhero
nico how do you like batman when he does
this dumb disappearing thing all the
time nico he comes in today and he's
just flying off the handle about batman
my favorite superhero now is batman
actually a superhero or is he just a
billionaire who works out a lot i don't
know the thing is is he's got this great
disappearing act that's sort of the
epitome of his style his finesse and his
stealth nico apparently doesn't think
it's realistic there's a lot of things
about superheroes that aren't realistic
and i'm willing to discuss those things
but this is actually realistic first off
if a billionaire went out there and
started doing vigilante justice no one
would have it we got angry at jeff bezos
for launching a rocket so but you know
there's another problem with batman
every time it happens it's super
distracting and it's whenever he
disappears in the middle of a
conversation it would never play out
like that people would immediately like
oh where'd he go oh he's probably behind
the couch and they'd go over they'd walk
over and batman would be freaking
crouched behind the couch like oh don't
look at me and no one would ever like it
that's not what he's doing though he's
actually disappearing he's just hiding
quickly when people look away it's so
juvenile
like people would never react how they
do in the cartoon in the movies but he
actually disappears what do you mean by
disappearance define disappears
he vanishes what do you mean like he
turns invisible have you never studied
the
the martial arts of
ninja
ninjas are famous for disappearing when
you're saying disappearing what you
really mean to be saying is hiding
quickly well obviously his physical form
is not vanishing from the earth he's not
a
multiversal being right it's like oh
hide and seek time with batman like of
course everybody's going to nearly stop
what they're doing i'm going to go look
for where batman just went i'm going to
show you that i can pull batman
disappearances around here and i haven't
studied the ancient arts of ninjai it
works for batman he's a human being i'm
a human being not only are you going to
see that a it's possible to disappear
but also that their reaction isn't going
to immediately be just to look for you
it's gonna be a stunned awe of disbelief
so you're gonna attempt to do the batman
disappearing thing in real life against
real people to prove to me not only is
it an effective way to end the
conversation
but people will react like they do in
this in the movie in the cartoon that's
exactly what i'm gonna do if you prove
to me that the batman vanishing thing
actually works in real life i will never
doubt batman again nor will i ever
complain about batman to you ever again
you got yourself a deal
business
so batman
yeah he knows martial arts he's a
billionaire he's got all the technology
at his disposal from wayne enterprises
but what he also has is a little bit of
magic and i know a friend that you also
know who also knows a little bit of
magic so first we're going to call him
hey what's up hey freddy how's it going
good man we need a magician's advice
okay all right hit me up we're doing
this thing where i'm gonna prove to nico
that batman's disappearing acts are
actually feasible in real life
and i just need a little bit of
foundational advice about how you go
about sleight of hand so that i can
apply it to my slight of body techniques
it's less about like looking at things
and being like oh look over here look
over here because people's eyes are
really fast right it's very easy to use
for you to just like look in one
direction building something that's
happening yeah it's more about
managing when the ups and downs are in
terms of your natural attention span
right so there's a lot of stuff that
happens when you're like oh it feels
like the trick is over and what you're
exploiting is you explain the fact that
you've finished the thing and then
you're leaning back in your chair
socially telling the other person like
okay this is done i can relax my my you
know sort of hunting mode looking for
things right the moment we start
performing it's like there's no way you
can get someone to look in another
direction because they're actively
looking at you they're looking for what
you're doing um and it's impossible to
be faster than you know just them
staring at you and staring and burning
you down
so a lot of the times it's that moment
when you're like okay cool it's done
you're leaning back and then in that
moment of relaxation they're no longer
burning you and looking for stuff yeah
then you can kind of get you get away
with so much more than that you get away
with stuff that's almost explicit um
because they're not expecting that
that's what the expectation is
so that's when you actually pull the
trick but what what what is your
personal opinion on this do you think
batman's disappearances are realistic
for a human being i think if he was
really doing it he's much closer than
you think
no he's not god he's probably like just
underneath that great
this guy's kind of a loser i think the
only way you can tell is to actually do
something like depend on somebody right
that's the only way you're really gonna
get someone's reacted okay so there's um
two things we're gonna try one thing is
the obvious technique of just hiding now
the other technique we're gonna try is
disappearing moving out of the space but
for this one given all the stuff up here
we're just gonna try hiding no one ever
comes up here except for basically
jordan and christian so nobody knows
what it looks like or what it's supposed
to look like now that's great because we
can use the sort of over saturation of
materials and space up here to work to
our advantage what we're going to do is
we're going to hide an envelope
underneath this bin i'll have it
sticking out so you can kind of see it
so you're not just like looking for it
and then turning around and asking me
where it is
i have a little secret to reveal to you
since last time i was in the studio i
have hidden
an envelope in the studio and i was
wondering if anyone would find it that's
all just a distraction they're going to
be on hunter mode as freddie said when
they get into this environment because
they're going to be looking for
something suspicious it's it's right
there
are you all right of course i'm all
right i'm hard-headed so i'm going to
immediately explain to them what the
point is only the fact that i can't tell
them what's in the envelope then i'm
going to relax i'm sorry i wish i could
assist you it's part of the process but
i need you to go over there find the
envelope open it it'll be like okay this
is simple i understand i don't know
what's in the envelope but i'm going for
it as soon as they do that i'm going to
hide over here
what the heck
nick and i have an arrangement of hats
set up here to distract them from what
is ultimately going to be my disguise
it's like hiding in plain sight we have
a hat it's going to go on my head
and then i'm going to duck down and as i
duck down i'm going to throw this shoe
so that it lands on the stairs and it
sounds like somebody just ran down the
stairs and then i will hide
it is just a pile of hats only batman's
here
what's going on
it's just an envelope of fat stacks
[Music]
[Laughter]
you just got batman you just got batman
dude you weren't supposed to find me i'm
batman
i was like wait a minute is that a real
party
i think it worked to a 90 success i
turned around and you were gone i was
like
you definitely batman me for a moment
there i was legit like and then i came
back and you were gone
now i'm just picturing like bruce wayne
like going
i think it's going well but we haven't
perfected it quite yet all right jake
best of luck to batman everyone else
last time i was here i hid an envelope
upstairs
and i thought hey maybe somebody will
find it in which case if they do this
video will go one way if they don't find
it the video will go another way no one
found it so now it's going that way okay
inside of this envelope what is
perceived as a normal piece of
information i need you to interpret to
me
what it is
your first impressions of what you find
will be critical to how you interpret it
okay
sure
[Music]
whoa
dude jake literally just disappeared
holy that was crazy
i'm being totally serious what the hell
he just
he like vanished all right so far the
experiment's working out marvelously but
it's almost too easy so this time i'm
gonna see how close i can get to them
when i actually disappear and then i'm
just gonna step back in here
[Music]
i'm like on edge dude i'm like
i'm like looking in all directions
jake
where'd you go man
what do you think
i think you're trying to help
hello guys we have a very special
merchandise announcement now with covet
and everything it was really hard to get
merch manufactured so what we did is we
spent the last year coming up with some
top tier designs just for you and we
also restocked a bunch of stuff that was
previously out of stock in our store and
it's all available right now we've been
asked to get women's merch in there well
guess what we finally went out and did
it we've got crop top we've got women's
cuts we've got hats we've got jackets
we've got long sleeves we've got short
sleeves we've got backpacks we've got
joggers anything that you want maybe
you're looking to get in early and get
something for a loved one for christmas
or maybe something for yourself now is
the time to do it because we order this
merch in limited batches so that we can
make sure that it's a high enough
quality and that it's available to you
at a relatively reasonable cost that
usually means it sells out pretty quick
so if you're a website subscriber at
cord or digital you can get 15 off if
you're not i would just recommend
getting in the store now while it's
still available because by next week a
lot of it's probably gonna be gone and
orders of 75 or more in the us get free
shipping guys we even have air
fresheners have you ever wondered what
an overheating red smells like or maybe
a brand new green screen suit anyways
i'm just super happy that we were able
to finally get this out there it's been
a year in the making so i hope you like
it head on over there now it's available
signing off
[Music]
hi i guess jake went out and uh did some
experiments he did some real research
mountains of research nico and i'm about
to find out what the findings were the
findings were just as surprising to me
as i think they would be to you
which is why i don't think anyone found
the envelope but it's it's right there
oh
are you all right of course i'm all
right i'm hard-headed
so watch your head and uh it's right
there
there she lies
[Music]
nick
can you imagine just showing somebody
look around for jake or for batman for
like 30 seconds
so we're just like huh
i don't know i don't believe that
at all man
this is so ominous
open it up
[Music]
all right so i hid the envelope up here
hoping somebody would find it um
it's right there
and uh
it's right here yeah right there
[Music]
wait jake wants to run away
jake
[Music]
i'm like on edge dude i'm like
i'm like looking in all directions yeah
i got it so did you did you make sure
you pick up dobie when you do
it what did you did you put something
inside of it
okay
[Music]
dang it oh he left
what are you up to dude
how would you expect anyone to think
this is out of place at all well it's an
envelope i'm sorry my my angle on this
is the peeking
[Laughter]
because it's like
[Music]
whoa
jake literally just disappeared holy
that was
crazy being totally serious what the
hell
is that give you an actual reaction that
batman
you didn't see that but trust me that
jake literally just
completely disappeared okay uh anyways
uh the envelope is right there
and within it
is the information gotcha gotcha that's
why
okay
[Music]
cargill's not suspicious at all
okay
dude can you like
there be your destiny
that that envelope right there
there's nothing in the oven
[Music]
weird going over here
it's in the envelope yeah
what can i expect here
there's nothing god damn it
nothing
what the hell is going on here
i think this experiment went
phenomenally well because the thing is
when you're in the middle of a
conversation with people they're not
contextualized to people just
disappearing in the middle of the
conversation so no one's expecting it no
one is expecting it so much that nico
you're not expecting it right now
[Music]
oh man i the moment jake started talking
to camera i was like he's gone
anymore
jake's dipped
there you have it so nico now that you
know that it's possible in a moment
to disappear do you think that people
would really search for batman after
what we found you know i think i think
the scenes in batman are like half true
actually there's definitely a little bit
of like elaboration to them
but there's some truth
i think i think in reality a lot of
people are just like
oh they're a little annoyed that batman
would just leave when they're talking
and definitely some people would be like
batman
i gotta get props though because your
disappearing act was really good in
almost every single one of these i guess
people just take it as kind of a rude
way to end a conversation batman would
say it's mysterious and it upholds his
legacy as the dark knight but
if there's any other tropes from movies
that you guys want to see us put to the
test with some of our cinematic science
experiments uh let us know in the
comments down below we'll give them a
shot i think the evidence speaks for
itself let us know what you think
because clearly oh i mean what do you
think nico you know i think you make
some really good points there
oh